i believe the senate should immediately
pass three house pass bills
to close loopholes that allow gun
purchases
purchasers to bypass the background
checks
the vast majority of the american people
including gun owners believe there
should be background checks
before you purchase a gun as was noted
earlier
hundreds of thousands of people have
been denied guns
because of the background checks what
more would have happened
these bills one require background
checks for anyone purchasing a gun
at a gun show or an online sale
most people don't know you walk into a
store and you buy a gun you have a
background check
but you go to a gun show you can buy
whatever you want and no background
check
second thing is to close the char
whispering noise with charleston
loophole
like people here i spent time down at
that church in charleston
what happened is someone was allowed
to get the gun used to kill those
innocent people of the church service
if the fbi hasn't
didn't complete the background check
within three days
there's a process it wasn't done in
three days according to charleston
loophole you get to buy the gun
they bought the gun and killed a hell of
a lot of innocent people
who invited him to pray with them
and three the violence camp summon act
which the so-called clothes
the boyfriend and stalking loopholes to
keep guns out of the hands of people
found by a court to be an abuser
and continuing threat i held over a
thousand hours of hearings
to pass the violence against women act
and one thing came through
if in fact a stay away order
an order preventing
the abuser from coming in a certain
distance
of the person he has abused or she has
abused
and now the idea that they can
own a weapon when they have a court
order
saying they are an abuser
these are some of the best tools we have
right now to prevent gun violence and
save lives
but all these bills they had supported
both democrats and republicans in the
house
and universal background checks are
supported by the vast majority of
american people
and i might add the vast majority of
responsible gun owners
let me be clear this is not a partisan
issue
among the american people this is a view
by the american people as an american
issue
and i'm willing to work with anyone to
get these done